start tonight with a focus on east las
vegas that's where a new city initiative
is zeroing in in an effort to help
businesses as well as families so it's
called our future and it's a part of the
city's 2050 master plan christian
casadas takes a closer look at the road
map that can't happen without your input
that's right guys well this really is a
road map into 2050 now the city is
looking to grow and improve the housing
public infrastructure and neighborhood
services among other things well tonight
residents we spoke to say they are
excited for the future
i feel right now that the people need
more places to hang out leslie ayala has
been working at this ice cream shop near
bonanza and charleston for the last six
months she says sprucing up the
neighborhood would only help business i
would love people to come in and get ice
cream to go and go to a park you know
better parks because i see other places
where they have nice new playgrounds
that is the focus of the city's 2050
master plan a road map to enhance and
grow economic development services
schools and housing for councilwoman
olivia diaz that means change what are
we missing what are we lacking what are
what are some missed opportunities that
we haven't really
been able to push and move forward so
we're looking to transform
east las vegas into something bigger and
greater diaz says the time to act is now
and wants all 75 thousand residents in
her ward to participate in the survey
answering questions like what
improvements do you want to see and what
do you like dislike about east las vegas
if we don't hear from you then you're
missing the opportunity to voice what
your wish list is
while 2050 might seem like a lengthy
road map ayala says it's a start for a
bright future sometimes the lights go
out here and it's not the best for our
business sometimes throwing out the
trash and while seeing homeless people
back there times it does get me scared
but you do the best that you can
well the survey is very important
according to the councilwoman because
projects take time for example a simple
road project she says can take anywhere
between two to three years that is why
she says the time to speak up is right
now on the link that we have available
for you right now on our website
eightnewsnow.com christian casa is live
local now